nous sommes en guerre il est midi pile
nous sommes le 17 mars 2020 la france
est officiellement confiné une situation
historique annoncée par le président de
la république la veille plus le droit de
sortir sauf pour se soigner faire ses
courses ou aller travailler
une autorisation dérogatoire de sortie
fait alors son apparition
plusieurs déplacements reste possible
mais il faudra vous munir de
l'autorisation de déplacement
dérogatoire les élèves des écoles
collèges lycées sont priés de rester
chez eux
les commerces et la culture sont à
l'arrêt le 26 mars plus de 50% de
l'activité économique des yvelines et
stopper le deuxième tour des élections
municipales reporter ce ne sera que mi
avril qu emmanuel macron donne une date
pour le déconfinement le 11 mai c'est
pour cela que le confinement le plus
strict doit encore se poursuivre
jusqu'au lundi 11 mai et ce 11 mai est
enfin là les yvelinois comme tous les
français se ruent chez les coiffeurs
notamment les écoles du département
retrouve les rires des enfants avec un
protocole sanitaire renforcée le 2 juin
c'est au tour des restaurants et des
bars uniquement en terrasse en ile de
france mais c'est déjà ça
la culture retrouve aussi son public
quinze semaines après le premier le
second tour des élections municipales
est organisée le 28 juin
avec l'été vient l'accalmie mais aussi
le relâchement des gestes-barrières jour
de fête nationale
le président annonce l'obligation du
port du masque en intérieur le préfet
des yvelines jean jacques brot applique
émettant l'obligation de ce port du
masque dans les marchés brocantes et
vide-greniers dès le 15 août septembre
et là et la rentrée donc masqué dans les
écoles jusqu'à 11 ans et dans les
entreprises également le département des
yvelines distribuer alors cet équipement
devenu objet du quotidien
aussi les dépistages se généraliser sur
tout s'accélère à saint quentin en
yvelines
le vélodrome nationale se transforme en
centre de dépistage du coc vide
autre mesure le 14 octobre le
gouvernement décide de placer
l'ile-de-france sous couvre-feu de 21h à
6h du matin et ce qui devait arriver
arriva le 29 octobre le deuxième
confinement est acté et c'est le grand
retour des attestations mais depuis
quelques heures ce n'est pas une mais
trois attestations qui sont disponibles
sur le site du gouvernement et sur
l'application tous antico vide 24
novembre un plan de déconfinement est
présenté par étapes
mais tout ne se passe pas comme prévu
quelques semaines plus tard un nouveau
couvre feu national est instauré de 20
heures à 6 heures du matin cette fois ci
seule exception le soir de noël le 24
décembre et justement fin décembre un
espoir
la campagne de vaccination commence le
31 décembre quatorze résidents de
l'ehpad mon repos de sartrouville marque
l'entrée des yvelines dans cette
campagne vaccinale mais malgré le début
de la vaccination le 16 janvier
le couvre-feu est une nouvelle fois
avancé à 18h les yvelines comme 68
autres départements sont toujours
considérées comme zones d' alerte
renforcée
les conférences de presse du
gouvernement s'enchaînent et le 22
février nice et dunkerque se retrouve
confiné le week end
mi mars l'île de france y échappe pour
le moment mais pour combien de temps
encore